ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
COMPANY AND THE SQUAD ARE ALL
TALK AND NO ACTION, WE WILL
EXPLAIN STRAIGHT AHEAD.
FIRST US MORE ON TONIGHT'S TOP
STORY, SENATOR TOM COTTON IS
WITH US.
SENATOR, GOOD TO HAVE YOU COME I
WANT TO GO TO YOUR COMMENTS IN
PARTICULAR THAT WE JUST PLAYED,
AND YOU SAID, YOU KNOW, THAT
LETTER -- YOU ARE REFERRING TO
THE LETTER ABOUT PARENTS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS, YOU CALLED HIS
DIRECTIVE, HIS PERFORMANCE
SHAMEFUL, AND THANK GOD YOU ARE
NOT ON THE SUPREME COURT, AND
YOU SHOULD RESIGN.
I SAT BACK AND I WAS GRATEFUL
YOU SAID IT, SENATOR, BECAUSE IT
IS A DISGRACE, AND I DIDN'T SEE
HIM GIVE AN ANSWER THAT MADE ME
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT HE
UNDERSTOOD THE SEVERITY OF WHAT
WENT OUT HERE.
>> NO, HE DIDN'T, SEAN, AND
THANK GOODNESS MERRICK GARLAND
IS NOT ON THE SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE HE HAS REVEALED HIMSELF
TO BE A FAR LEFT IDEOLOGUE IN
THE JOB OF ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE IS SICK
HE 60 FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON PARENTS WHO WANTED
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS AT
SCHOOL BOARDS.
CAN THOSE MEETINGS BE
CONTENTIOUS AND HE DID?
BUT THEY ACCUSE THEM OF BEING
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, AND ON THAT
BASIS ALONE, HE DIRECTED U.S.
ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TOD
ABOUT THEIR SCHOOL
INDOCTRINATING THEIR KIDS TO
HATE AMERICA, OR THEIR KIDS
BEING FORCED TO WEAR MASKS, OR
NOT BEING IN PERSON IN CLASS, OR
ONE PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS CASE,
YOU HAD THE WALK SCHOOL BOARD
AND SUPERINTENDENT OF
LOUDOUN COUNTY, VIRGINIA, WHO
COVERED UP THE RAPE, SEAN, THE
RAPE OF A 15-YEAR-OLD GIRL BY A
BOY WEARING GIRLS CLOTHING.
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO PASS A
TRANSGENDER POLICY DURING
PRIDE MONTH.
WELL, I'M NOT SURPRISED, HER
FATHER GOT A LITTLE HEATED AT
THAT BOARD MEETING.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, AS HE
SHOWED.
NOW WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT
THAT IS THAT SUPERVISOR, THE GUY
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
THAT SHOULD KNOW BETTER, DENIED
ANY KNOWLEDGE OF IT, BUT YET THE
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT
ACKNOWLEDGED IT HAD BEEN
INVESTIGATING IT FROM THE FIRST
DAY.
ISN'T THAT CORRECT?
>> YEAH, AND SEAN, A JULIE COURT
JUDGE JUST ANNOUNCED THIS WAS IN
FACT A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND SEAN, THAT SCHOOL BOARD OF
SUPERINTENDENTS TRANSFERRED THAT
BOY TO ANOTHER SCHOOL WHERE HE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ANOTHER GIRL.
ALL BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT IT
TO INTERFERE WITH PASSING A
TRANSGENDER POLICY DURING
PRIDE MONTH.
YOU KNOW, SEAN, IF THERE EVER IS
ACTUAL VIOLENCE OR THREATS OF
VIOLENCE TO THE SCHOOL BOARD,
I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT LOCAL
POLICE AND SHERIFFS DEPUTIES CAN
HANDLE IT.
MAYBE MERRICK GARLAND'S
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOULD BE
LOOKING INTO
LOUDOUN COUNTY COUNTY SCHOOL
BOARD SUPERINTENDENT WHO CAN'T
PROTECT YOUNG GIRLS FROM BEING
RAPED BY VOICE PRETENDING TO BE
GIRLS.
>> Sean: AND IT IS A BIG ISSUE
IS FOR PARENTS WE WILL SEE -- WE
WILL KNOW MAYBE A WEEK FROM
TONIGHT WHAT HAPPENED IN
VIRGINIA BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG
ISSUE FOR PARENTS AND ALL THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
I WAS REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
PRESSED HIM, AND HE DIDN'T GIVE
A PARTICULARLY GOOD ANSWER ON
ANTHONY FAUCI AND WHETHER OR NOT
HE WAS TRUTHFUL.
NOW WE HAVE ANTHONY FAUCI'S
EMAILS.
WE HAVE THE 900 PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS FROM THE INTERCEPT.
AND NOW WE HAVE THE NIH LETTER
THAT CAME OUT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT,
GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH ON
CORONAVIRUS SAYS AT THE WUHAN
VIROLOGY LAB WAS FUNDED BY TAX
DOLLARS AND THAT ANTHONY FAUCI
KNEW?
>> NONE AT ALL, SEAN.
SPEAKING AT PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
RESIGN IN DISGRACE,
TONY FAUCI SHOULD RESIGN IN
DISGRACE BEARD HE REPEATEDLY
LIED TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
BY CONGRESS, SAYING HIS AGENCY
DID NOT FUND THIS RISKY,
DANGEROUS RESEARCH IN CHINA, OF
ALL PLACES.
NOW HIS AGENCY HAS ADMITTED
THAT.
HE HAS LOST ALL MORAL AUTHORITY
TO SERVE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND TO GIVE ANY KIND OF GUIDANCE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HIS NEXT PUBLIC APPEARANCE
SHOULD NOT BE AT THE CONGRESS,
IT SHOULD BE AT THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
JOE BIDEN'S OVERALL PRESIDENCY,
FROM AFGHANISTAN TO THE BORDER
TO MORE PEOPLE DIED IN 2021 OF
COVID, INFLATION, THE ECONOMY,
ENERGY, FOREIGN POLICY, CAN YOU
NAME A SINGLE SUCCESS, SENATOR?
BECAUSE I READ AND WATCH EVERY
DAY, EVERY DETAIL OF WHAT HE IS
DOING, AND I DON'T SEE ONE AREA
WHERE I CAN SAY "WOW, HE IS
DOING A GOOD JOB HERE OR HERE OR
HERE."
I DON'T SEE IT.
>> NO, SEAN, ALTHOUGH I GUESS HE
SEEMS TO HAVE GENERATED A LOT OF
ENTHUSIASM THAT COLLEGE FOOTBALL
GAMES.
[LAUGHS]
EVERY SATURDAY, GIVEN THE CHANCE
OF YOUNG COLLEGE STUDENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, MANY AMERICANS
HAVE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
NO, BEEN IN TOTAL SHAMBLES.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN WASHINGTON
FOR 50 YEARS.
NO ONE EVER THOUGHT HE WAS UP
FOR THE JOB OF PRESIDENT, AND WE
HAVE SEEN THAT IN SPADES OVER
THE LAST NINE MONTHS.
>> Sean: SENAT